as long as there's been television
there's been people on television
selling you the latest and the greatest
one of a kind never been seen before
mind-blowing must-have item
but does it ever really deliver
remember the fire festival from just a
few years ago
all these models like in the bahamas the
most insane festival the world has ever
seen island getaway turned disaster it
became very barbaric
what was supposed to be the can't miss
party of the millennium turned out to be
a catastrophe the models that were
promised never showed up the gourmet
food they advertised turned out to be
something from a school cafeteria
and things got so bad the party's
organizer
even ended up in jail
but pr scams like this oh they've been
around new coke was hailed as the future
of soda and was going to take the
beverage world by storm in the 1980s
well that didn't work just a few months
later they were back to the classic
and how about the segway
once billed as the most revolutionary
change to transportation since the horse
and buggy
became nothing more than a punch line in
bad movies
how's that is that valid enough for you
that was pretty valid huh
now most of these marketing failures
have little consequence
most of the wrong people still get paid
but at least they leave the scene of the
crime
but that same thing can't be said about
alexandria ocasio-cortez
the new coke of politics
in 2018 aoc was the fresh face on the
block after she upset long-time democrat
incumbent congressman joe crowley the
media fell head over heels for their it
girl
she ran because she was focused on the
issues that people in her community
cared about alexandria ocasio-cortez she
is the hottest ticket in democratic
politics she absolutely is alexandria
ocasio-cortez is just a superstar i
haven't seen anyone in recent years ever
really being able to harness that social
media following she's 29 years old she
is a woman she is hispanic and most
importantly she represents this fusion
of movement politics and electoral
politics that seems to be where the
energy on the left is right now aoc was
all sizzle no steak literally i think
she's vegan
but her quick rise to the top wasn't an
accident she was a planned packaged and
processed candidate sold to a hungry
young generation by a slick and shallow
media
empty calories cortez
her story begins with bernie sanders his
failed run for the presidency in 2016.
we're a campaign volunteer and silicon
valley executive
sakat
chakarabhati
began recruiting hundreds of
progressives for house races
chakrabati identified aoc and after
realizing his product's potential he
decided he run her campaign he cast her
she won
and then he named himself her chief of
staff
so it's safe to say that with chaka
bharati writing the script aoc was
making noise on the left
he was the brains behind the green new
deal not aoc
which is actually a compliment because
that whole thing's crazy
but the more a plan doesn't make sense
the more the media loves it
in early 2019 she appeared on the cover
of time magazine and rolling stone as
the anointed heir the future of the
democrat party
but a funny thing happened once her
mastermind and chief of staff exited in
august 2019.
ocasio-cortez lost the heat on her
fastball
vaughn's showing some signs of fatigue
out there he seems to have lost some zip
on his fastball
without the man behind the curtain she
stopped making a splash on social media
never goes viral anymore her timing and
wit vanished with her chief of staff
was he aoc's oz
oh most definitely
most people no longer care what aoc has
to say about health care while she makes
dinner in her little apartment
and when she's pressed on real issues
she has no real answers
medicare for all would save the american
people a very large amount of money why
aren't we incorporating the cost of all
the funeral expenses of those who die
because they can't afford access to
health care we look at these figures and
we say oh unemployment is low everything
is fine right well unemployment is low
because everyone has two jobs you use
the term the occupation of palestine
what did you mean by that oh um
i think it what i meant is like the the
settlement
in fact did aoc run for congress just to
be famous
she's on the red carpet more than ryan
seacrest
ocasio-cortez says she represents the
downtrodden of society but has she
actually done anything for her
constituents
since taking over new york's 14th
congressional district the area has
fallen on hard times aoc forced amazon
out of queens pushing as many as 40 000
jobs out of the area
jobs that were sorely needed in at that
district wages are down and crime is up
so as she fails her constituents we
wanted to know what they really think of
her not what cnn or vanity fair chuck
todd thinks of her we know what chuck
thinks and we wish we didn't
so we sent some producers to her
district to ask around
who represents you in congress it's aoc
alexandria castro cortez aoc
ocasio-cortez
i'm guessing it's aoc can you tell me
who represents you in congress
no
does aoc sound familiar
hello never heard of her who's aoc what
would you say aoc stands for
um
maybe
aoc stands for democracy basically you
believe in democracy don't you what do
you think aoc stands for
a shelf
i think it's interesting that she's down
in florida
you know partying i think aoc dresses
fantastic you look fabulous what
specifically would you say aoc has done
for this district
what she's done for the district is
harder for me to name specifically i'm
not really too sure a lot of photo ops
aoc she killed 40 000 amazon jobs that
could have come to this community do you
support that yes i do oh
how could you even say that it wasn't
necessarily a bad thing there's a lot of
jobs here already she didn't kill it out
of you know mean-spiritedness uh maybe
not there's a lot of people that needs
jobs and stuff like that people are
struggling and that would have been
great to have all those jobs let me ask
you about crime it's up big time here in
the city what has she done to address
that
i haven't heard anything about
her addressing crime she was behind the
bail reform
and that turned out to need a lot of
tweaking
we might have to tweak that a little bit
things are a lot more expensive here in
queens so do you think aoc is doing
anything to help the the rise in prices
i hope they are do i see it no is it
obviously expensive
i mean it's one banana michael what
could it cost ten dollars if you could
tell your congresswoman something what
would you say
i will vote for you in 2004 if you run
for president
what year is it you look like a
wonderful dressed new yorker
keep refining yourself everybody you
know has to get better at their job i
can do
better maybe a little less idealism and
a little more trying to
help working class people leave office
do us all a favor
[Music]
even her own voters can't come up with
any answers on how she's combating the
out-of-control crime in new york city or
how she's working to fight the surging
inflation they're dealing with this is
because aoc is among the least
productive members of congress
she's sponsored 34 bills in congress not
a single one of them has been passed
into law
so what is she doing all day in
what is she congress
i never know what she's doing
back there turns out she's doing a whole
lot of nothing but don't tell her that
because aoc thinks if you criticize her
it just means you really want to date
her
well we just found you a bunch of dates
congresswoman right there in your
district
aoc is just the latest example of
politicians who've done nothing for the
people they represent and we'll be
calling them out one by one
the media might love her now but it's
only a matter of time before something
new comes around
then they have to get the old product
off the shelves hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else